vi chiedo scusa se sono così sciatto in
questo mi sincero però è molto tardi sto
aspettando il mio volo per indianapolis
passerò un giorno totalmente da solo
arriverà lorenzo nel mentre che mi porta
la mia bellissima videocamera e andiamo
lì perché c'è un evento che ragazzi ma
che ve lo dico a fare c'è l'evento di
harry potter guida king live mamma mia
sono elettrizzati gloria sto partendo
per la ci vediamo fra poco
di fare finalmente ciao non potevo non
trovarlo in camera perché titanic
perché non lo so signori che stiamo
andando a cena e ho scelto io
un ristorante che secondo me rappresenta
la patria nessuno cucina l'italia non è
anche in italia signori meglio di buca
di beppo madame e monsieur è un
ristorante italiano oggi mangeremo
dall'incredibile buca di beppo la vera
cucina italiana
all'entrata notiamo subito che sono
molto confusi perché c'è ilove inter
manche anche ai lov roma ma c'è anche la
juve ma c'è anche il milan
signori siamo seduti e oltre a sembrano
locale a luci rosse
lorenzo ci vuole dire qualcosa dici pure
l'ho fatto solo perché soprattutto
adesso che ho visto minuto nel caso vi
steste chiedendo ma tu che cosa mangi lo
è io in realtà sono già stato alla
partita di baseball
ho mangiato un sacco e abbiamo ordinato
ovviamente le famosissime fettuccine
alfredo ma non hanno altri l'ospedale lo
spetto c ne sono arrivate alfredo spa
padella fettuccine
vicino quindi sono ma sono lì in mezzo
detto non li voglio io non li vogliono
che schifo cosa facciamo beh abbiamo le
nostre fettuccine alfredo dobbiamo
ancora capire chi alfredo signori la
gente per la patria fa qualsiasi cosa è
oggi io misi freak i malati
io non so veramente cosa dire mi sono
perso in buca di beppo park forza parma
si ci mancava quel mamma mia
siamo vivi io scappiamo macchine
macchine che sto giocando ai riporta la
mia tra niente la macchina fa si gioca
se ne riparla qua 80 anni che di cuore
perché cosa fanno
quindi ogni vento mio dio l'ho fatto
fuori il suo quadro
chi è libero nel mentre c'era anche la
macchina bisogna prega le macchine con
le comete o
[Musica]
almeno una ragazzi siamo finalmente a
casa mia mi sento più a casa che abbiamo
questo non è il tomorrow when he meglio
e guicciardi una hit di harry porter
siamo qua grazie a warner bros che ci ha
veramente deliziati di questo parco
incredibile a tema harry potter come
vedete c'è già anche harry che stalin
adesso andiamo in giro perché ci sono un
sacco di cose delle ande e soprattutto
l'evento
e stato anche fatto perché ha raggiunto
nel nuovo aggiornamento una nuova
feature che ti permette di avere i
draghi i draghi come i draghi si trovano
ognuno nella propria regione come
venerdì potter e nel libro oggi e domani
si troveranno in questo parco tutti
insieme e poi finito l'evento si
troveranno ognuno nella propria regione
quindi se riesco a chi sa parli tutti
oggi a chiamarli o [ __ ] catturi con il
senso acchiappa linee senso di trovarli
anche perché effettivamente di catturare
un drago con la pokémon andiamo
[Musica]
amico di tutti va bene la magia ma
secondo me se continuate a camminare col
cavo del power bank che va per terra
secondo me per terra ci finite voi non
vi salva niente prestito che siamo sotto
un tendone tipico stile poter jano
incredibile ma quando entri se le
candele che l'impatto sono semplicemente
a perdere ma c'è il trucco silente un
fatto fiere quando cerchi lorenzo devi
sempre guardare dove ci può essere un
posto seduto e lui
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ragazzi quindi c'è un tipo che quello
raggio che appena un lato che c'è un
drago ii e orate l'affluenza di gente
l'essere umano è una specie strana
andiamo a scoprirlo come potete vedere
l'essere umano non gliene frega niente
dell'ambiente circostante ma gliene
frega dei giochi lego e lui il pr solo
di quello lì è tutto fiero di voi è
l'anima della festa rega quello che gli
battono una mano sulla spalla anche
quello che c'è la macchina piega e lui
urla draghi ha detto il passaggio di qui
drago gigante questi sei gallese comune
verde ragazzi sapranno far fuori anche
questo gallese sta andando forte
impara a fare il dialetto è andato ha
vinto
vedi tutti questi ragazzi che stanno
giocando lì i miei diritti
se non è anche uno di gallese loro non
sono fallite gallese ma non indoor i
miei diretti asean torinesi ce la fa ce
la farete gallese era in quella di chi
eri a a chieri di annapolis prendi sono
un pullman si fayad and friends e da lì
quando questa la visita molto bene come
star wars ha semoli laiso amici lei
sprechi amici stranieri ai bisogni di
amici di amici così punto su casi la
chiesa è bisogno di amici
ragazzi pare che sia l'ora
pare che siano regali questi casi poiché
sono solo
sì napoli cioè non ho capito bene se
diceva potete pure prenderli potete non
dovete neanche toccarli non ho capito si
dicevano quello però
aia non drago gigantesco bene devo
rimanere nel cerchio per un tot e poi
fare la magia o schiattando zio devono
scattare è anche perché sennò poi non
abbiamo la parte bella che ci provo e
promettono molto bene il colpo che gli
ha sferrato è infatti non so neanche io
lo sto facendo ma come sei impegnato
davide
non so neanche come ho fatto perché ho
preso o pale e degli anti opa lei e
degli antipodi strada maestra vento di
ribattere pazzesco perché hanno
addirittura imitato silente ma guarda
[Musica]
ha dato molto divertente abbiamo girato
e abbiamo concluso questa operazione con
questori potter molto cool e noi siamo
felici perché abbiamo preso due da noi
l'altra abbia presi 5 2 di un tipo e
l'altro tipo ne abbiamo presi ma chi se
ne frega l'importante aver preso dei
draghi così almeno questo tornare a casa
e la mia mamma è contenta mamma sono
indianapolis per una buona ragione
ringrazio la warner invitate
indianapolis girate trovate draghi e se
non li trovate chiamate me quant'è 70
euro al minuto
facciamo una tariffa tu sei il manager
sparo prezzo gratis fa vg cerca manager
in descrizione trovate la mail oltre la
mail trovate anche il link per scaricare
il gioco perché è gratis
lo trovate sia su app store che su play
store che su storica ragazzi tra una
partita e l'altra mangiamo vi vorrei far
vedere il menu qua ragazzi abbiamo la
bellissima ti faccio notare abbiamo the
italian shopper che costituita da
costituiti da costituzione italiana che
è composta da crispi prosciutto
attenzione genoa salami bruttissimo
gennaio provolone parmesan questo
facciamolo non in italiano perché va be
agreed suite beppe signori e signori
quando non di tagli al prato e qui negli
ingredienti
la giardiniera io prendo questo ragazzi
mentre eravamo in giro per indianapolis
e abbiamo trovato delle robe bellissime
non mi riferivo a te no dopodiché
abbiamo trovato questo che il pendolo
della sabbia praticamente come funziona
che tu fai girare
cioè tu lanci questa fare l'affare gira
e con un movimento ellittico come
l'egocentrismo non ho solo detto non lo
toccare perché lui gira e tira proprio
una specie di flora del city mostro
mesta guardandomi a favore ma quello è
certo le sue gira dalla parte opposta
addirittura ti ho visto fare identico
ellittico ragazzi merchandising sul sito
in descrizione trovate anche questo
pendolo di sabbia firmato da me coach
orlando e di colore vero ma che roba
valenti forte
vedi più tenero veli di saranno mie un
giorno a quelli sono quelle sono
attrazioni per turisti e ai turisti si
fanno accalappiare la superò per
spendere i soldi per poter tifare
diretta da turisti bianchi capito
i ragazzi non ho potuto resistere perché
la fascino del turista arriva sempre per
primo se sei un uomo vero che non ero io
vero
salani
mamma mia ciao turista un attimo ho
pensato non essendoci veramente ragazzi
ho scelto giorno migliore per mettere
dei jeans fa veramente un tempo che
vorrei morire ea fondo sta roba io
faccio stiamo andando nello jano olio
ohio
raga pedalare in faticoso quindi io
schiavizzato verso la giornata così
molto bello ed allora mi piace più
veloce però iniziamo allora ghazi a me
piace l'america anche lorenzo perché un
paese molto tranquillo dove ognuno si fa
le sue vacanze tranquillo non succede
niente di strano
tutto tranquillo il rumore non esiste
proprio puoi star tranquillo
io rimango
[Musica]
allora non succede ma se per caso questa
è un'altra dovessero attaccare lorenzo
io faccio un miliardo di maledizione
sarebbe incredibile e comunque tutto
questo mentre lorenzo si schianta ho
scoperto che ad indianapolis hanno
inventato il viaggio nel tempo che è una
figata se ci pensate weyladt e li
potresti prendere per il tuo giardino
ma l'addio mio padre vale tutti quelli
messi insieme
[Musica]